اما في تطورات المعارك على الارض باقليم
جمباز الشرقيه اوكرانيا فقد اعلنتا
السلطات المواليه لروسيا في مقاطعه
لوجانسكو مقتل 13 شخصا جراء خاص في
الاوكراني بصواريخ هاي مارس وبالمدفعيه
استهدف مبانيه سكنيه اما في ايطاليا فقالت
السلطات المواليه لروسيا ان حصيله قتل
القذف الاوكرانيه ارتفع الى ثلاثه اشخاص
في المقابل على رفع السلطات الاوكرانيه
مقتل شخصين وجرحى اخرين في قصف روسيا
استهدف مبدا سكنيا
مناقشه هذه التطورات تطورات القصف الروسيه
الباحث في مركز استراتيجيات الدفاع وكذلك
من موسكو اندريوف الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي ونبدا معك السيد في في موسكو
ما هي اسباب استهداف كيف من جديد وبهذه
الكثافه
من هذه الحمله حمله
درب الصواريخ من قبل القوات الروسيه فقد
شرحها الرئيس الروسي السابق منفذ اليوم
بحسب ما قاله هو هناك اهداف عسكريه
بما فيه هنا تحتيه لها علاقه
بالطاقه
الانتاج الصناعي التي من شانها ان تساعده
اوكرانيا او العدو على انتاج المنتجات او
السلع العسكريه وكذلك التصدي في الميدان
يعني جريمه حرب باستهداف عمليه
مناطق مدنيه في في اوكرانيا
اعدام صيف وكان ااا كوكب بعض
عسكري او جرائم حرب لان روسيا
استهدفت فقط
اهدافا عسكريه او اهداف ترتبط بالبناء
التحتيه حيث ليس هناك عدد كبير من الضحايا
المدنيين
بعض الاشخاص الذين
اصيبوا خلال هذه الحمله
بفوز
عن بعض المرافق التي احيانا تستخدم من
الجانب الاوكراني من الجيش الاوكراني
ونحن كخبراء مستقلين من الصعب علينا ان
نقدر
نتحدث عنها هي فعلا تعتبر مدنيه
او ربما فيها بعض الاستخدامات العسكريه
للاسف هناك بعض الحالات خلال الحرب التي
استخدمت فيها القوات الاوكرانيه
مبانيه مدنيه لكي تتمركز فيها سيد
قرار الولايات المتحده عزمها ارسال انظمه
باتريوت الى اوكرانيا هل هذا القصر جاء
ردا على
وفي الامريكي
مباشر بين ادعاءات من واشنطن والحمله
العسكريه الروسيه لان هذه الحمله العسكريه
الروسيه مخطط لها وهذا النوع من العمليات
صعب وعلى نطاق واسع وبالتالي
تستغرق اسابيع من التحضير والاستعداد
وبتاعي ليس هناك رابط بينما ادعته امريكا
في الامس وما حصل اليوم